This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。不过现在，有一个令人兴奋的全新方式，帮你开启迈向更快乐生活之旅，这就是《快乐101》。这是一档全新的播客节目，由我，霍达·科特比主持。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些真诚、振奋人心且触动人心的电台访谈。打开免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“Joy 101”并立即收听。
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotopje is presented by CVS. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum.
由CVS为您呈献的由霍达·科特比主持的《快乐101》。那些眼神里空洞无物。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓得魂飞魄散。邪恶，醒醒吧。我是那个看到克里瓦茨和德皮波实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。
I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rapaport Stereo podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now.
我说，我是无辜的。我至死也不会承认。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听《Bone Valley》爆料中的“恶魔采石场”。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特，我的播客《I Am Rapaport Stereo Podcast》与你听过的任何节目都不同。如果你在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及其他任何吸引我注意的事情的强烈观点，那就赶紧订阅吧。
This kid, Jafar Jackson, should absolutely. positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to IMRAP report on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. For years, the unhoused have been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weed-en-House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created the show why I was unhoused on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast. The only podcast that shares unhoused stories and news from the unhoused perspective.
这个名叫贾法尔·杰克逊的孩子，绝对、百分之百应该因为饰演迈克尔·杰克逊而获得提名。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听IMRAP report。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被塑造成一个单一的群体。《We-n-House》是一档正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创立了这个节目。我们已经成长为获得两次韦比奖的播客。唯一一个从无家可归者视角分享无家可归者故事和新闻的播客。
Listen to Wey and House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got like so much more to do. Like Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now. That's the rate we got to be going.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Wey and House》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Chams》播客中，我们将与文化界最炙手可热的大咖对话，比如斯韦·李。你意识到自己有多传奇了吗？我很感激。我虽然看到了，但我觉得，天哪，我还有好多事要做。就像王子，他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在才发行了大约5张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。
Yep, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spake, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, let me get on my soapbox for a second and say, a boring life is a beautiful life. It is my belief that every single day we face this wall of content that we're going to be a beautiful life. We face this wall of content that we're wants to convince you that what you are doing isn't enough. And if you were to listen to this tidal wave of like videos and posts and whatnot, you would honestly believe that everybody has more
没错，这是一个好心态。无论哪个时代，《Drink Chams》都会为你带来最大牌的明星和最毫无保留的对话。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《Drink Chams》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十多岁的心理学。今天，请容许我发表一下高见，平淡的生活就是美好的生活。我相信，我们每天都面对着铺天盖地的网络内容，我们要过上美好的生活。我们面对着铺天盖地的网络内容，它想让你相信你正在做的事情还不够。如果你听信了这股排山倒海般的视频、帖子之类的内容，你真的会相信每个人都比你有
motivation than you, everybody has more friends than you, everybody has more clothes, more money, more kind of like action going on in their life. First of all, that's not true. But second, being boring is a radical act. There is no one to impress. There is no one to impress. There is no else's life that you want to copy because you like what you have. You have no idea how much agency that acceptance of what other people might not see as glamorous gives you. I also think the tidal wave is shifting and more of us are realizing how truly freeing it is to slow down and just go smaller and slower. It's a bit of, it's revolutionary. It's psychologically revolutionary for sure. So what we're going to talk about today is the beauty of the boring routine,
更多的动力，每个人都比你有更多的朋友，每个人都有更多的衣服，更多的钱，生活中有更多精彩刺激的事情。首先，这不是真的。但其次，平淡无奇是一种激进的做法。不需要给任何人留下深刻印象。不需要给任何人留下深刻印象。不需要去复制别人的生活，因为你喜欢自己拥有的一切。你根本无法想象，这种接受别人可能不觉得光鲜亮丽的东西，能给你带来多大的自主权。我也觉得这股潮流正在转变，我们越来越多的人开始意识到，慢下来、把生活过得更简单和缓慢是多么真正的解脱。这有点像，这是具有革命性的。心理学上的革命，这是肯定的。所以我们今天要谈论的是平淡日常的美好，
the boring rituals and why they're important and why they may open doors, you didn't even realize were available or were there, especially in your 20s. I also want to talk about how to cope with feeling like maybe you're wasting your youth and why that's absolutely not true. Let's talk about it. Why is the boring life beautiful? Stay with us. So what do I mean when I say a boring life?
枯燥的仪式感，以及为什么它们很重要，为什么它们会为你打开你甚至没有意识到存在的大门，尤其是在你二十多岁的时候。我还想聊聊如何应对那种觉得自己可能在浪费青春的感觉，以及为什么这绝对不是真的。我们来聊聊这个。为什么平淡的生活是美好的？请继续收听。那么当我谈到平淡的生活时，我是什么意思？
Because I feel like that's kind of open to interpretation. For me, and it may be different for you, a boring life is just one that I think has maybe been dismissed by social media because it's not as easy to sell into. It is the one where you don't buy new clothes every week because that's ridiculous. You don't need to go on lavish vacations every month to be happy because who can afford that? You don't need to be constantly engaged in drama or emotional extremes just to feel stimulated. But instead, you have firm boundaries. you have a routine you like, you have small luxuries, you have stability, tiny joys,
因为我觉得这有点见仁见智。对我来说，对你可能也不同，平淡的生活只是一种我觉得可能被社交媒体淡化的生活，因为它没那么容易被拿来营销。这就是那种你不会每周都买新衣服的生活，因为那太荒谬了。你不需要每个月都去豪华度假才能快乐，因为谁能负担得起那个？你不需要为了寻求刺激而不断陷入抓马或情绪极端中。相反，你有坚定的底线。你有一个自己喜欢的日常，你有小小的奢侈品，你有稳定性，有微小的快乐，
just peace really. When I kind of picture it for myself, it's very grammar coded. Maybe I'd use the term like slow maxing if I was that kind of person, but like, again, indulgence in simple pleasures, appreciation for what you have now without constantly desiring more, slowing down, simplicity. And from the outside, yeah, something that might look really boring or maybe lame. But when we get down to it, it is deeply nourishing and supremely fulfilling for our psychological needs. I don't think I'm the only one seeing this like mass conversion, mass trend back to this kind of simple, understated existence. We've noticed it in like the trend of the trad wife, but also just like in my friends and in
说真的，就是内心的平静。当我为自己想象这种生活时，它非常具有格调。如果我是那种人的话，我可能会用“慢节奏极限”这样的词，但话说回来，就是沉溺于简单的快乐，感恩你现在拥有的一切，而不是不断渴望更多，慢下来，简单。从外表上看，是的，这可能看起来真的很无聊，甚至有点逊。但当我们深入探究时，它对我们的心理需求有着极大的滋养和无与伦比的满足感。我不认为只有我一个人看到了这种大规模回归这种简单、低调生存方式的趋势。我们在“传统妻子”这种趋势中注意到了这一点，而且在我的朋友身上，也包括
myself included, this craving for a life that's more manageable when previously, you know, we really kind of ran on fumes and kind of had these very packed schedules and we thought that was success. Part of this is developmental as we get older, even within our 20s, which is, by the way, still very young, many people become, we just become less drawn to raw stimulation for its own sake. There was a very interesting study done in 2014 that looked at, I think, data from like almost 6,000 individuals. And they measured changes in impulsivity and sensation-seeking behaviors from the ages of 15 to 26. And what they noticed was that, obviously, as we get older, those impulses reduce.
在我自己身上，这种对更可控生活的渴望，而在此之前，你知道，我们真的是在透支精力，有着非常满档的日程安排，我们曾以为那就是成功。其中一部分是随着我们年龄增长而发生的心理发展，即便在我们二十多岁的时候——顺便说一句，这个年纪其实还很年轻——许多人，我们只是变得不再那么单纯为了刺激而追求刺激。2014年进行过一项非常有趣的研究，考察了，我记得是近6000名个体的数据。他们测量了15岁到26岁之间冲动性和寻求刺激行为的变化。他们注意到的是，很明显，随着我们年龄增长，这些冲动会减少。
But it specifically found that this drive towards the calm of boring life in our 20s is being driven by two things. Firstly, changes in our personality. And secondly, a linear decline in impulsivity and in risk-taking behavior and hunger for novelty. We kind of know what we want. We don't need raw excitement. to motivate us. Like, we have the pull and the drive of long-term gratification and long-term peace and long-term stability is more motivational and more convincing. Another part of this and why we notice this change is that in reality, like chaos eventually costs you too much and it loses
但研究具体发现，我们在二十多岁时对平静的平淡生活的这种向往，是由两件事驱动的。首先，我们性格的变化。其次，冲动性、冒险行为以及对新鲜感渴望的线性下降。我们某种程度上知道了自己想要什么。我们不再需要纯粹的兴奋来激励自己。就像，我们拥有长期满足感、长期平静和长期稳定的牵引力和驱动力，这更具激励性和说服力。这种转变的另一个部分，以及为什么我们注意到这种变化的原因是，现实中，混乱最终会让你付出太高昂的代价，而且随着我们年龄增长，它失去了
its attraction as we get older. When you're younger or like when you're still kind of constructing your sense of self, unpredictability, spontaneity, the pursuit of more I think that feels like proof that you are open and you're alive and you're an interesting person. It's also almost like proof that, you know, I'm young. Look at it. Like, look at this. I'm doing all these things. But over time, I think we do begin to notice how being constantly overwhelmed and stimulated
吸引力。当你更年轻的时候，或者当你还在构建自我意识的时候，不可预测性、随性、对更多的追求，我认为这感觉就像是你开放、充满活力且是一个有趣之人的证明。这几乎也像是证明，你知道，我年轻。看啊。就像，看看这个。我在做所有这些事情。但随着时间的推移，我认为我们确实开始注意到，不断感到不知所措和受到刺激，
is not necessarily the same thing as being fulfilled. And we also see the burnout that happens when we have plans every single night, when we are kind of living on just like the fumes and highs of life. It's not that we don't crave less life. We just crave less friction and we learn what we don't like about the chaos. Why does it feel weird to admit that though? Why does it feel weird to admit that we similarly want less, not less per se, but different? I think right before you were able to fully accept like, hey, actually, I don't care what other people say, I want this boring life. We have this thing, this kind of reaction that we actually call in psychology reactive.
并不一定等同于感到满足。我们也会看到，当我们每晚都有安排，当我们靠着生活中的透支和高光时刻勉强度日时，所产生的倦怠感。并不是说我们不渴望更少的生活。我们只是渴望更少的摩擦，并且我们了解了自己对混乱中不喜欢的部分。然而，为什么承认这一点感觉怪怪的呢？为什么承认我们同样想要更少——倒不是说更少本身，而是想要不同——会觉得奇怪呢？我认为，就在你能够完全接受诸如“嘿，实际上，我不在乎别人怎么说，我想要这种平淡的生活”之前，我们有一种反应，我们在心理学上称之为抗拒心理。
which is when it feels like our freedom to be young is being taken away, even if it's by our own choices, we kind of act out as like a last hurrah. What is really, what's, what's really coming down to is cognitive dissonance between what we're deeply craving internally and what the world around us has told us to desire and expect externally that feels like we're trapped between these two ways of living. There is this narrative that our 20s are supposed to be this incredibly fast-paced hustles. filled a thousand plans a weekend kind of life before like so-called real life begins. You know, you're meant to kind of front load the stress and socializing of life as an
也就是，当感觉我们做年轻人的自由被剥夺时，哪怕这是我们自己的选择，我们也会像最后狂欢一样做出叛逆的举动。这实际上归结为，在我们内心深处极度渴望的生活与周遭世界告诉我们应该去渴望和期待的外部生活之间存在认知失调，这让人感觉我们被困在这两种生活方式之间。有一种说法是，我们的二十多岁应该是一场节奏极快、充满拼搏的生活，在所谓真正的生活开始之前，充满着一个周末有一千个计划的生活。你知道，你本该在人生的前期阶段承受超额的压力和社交，作为
investment for later on. And yeah, at certain times in your life, it's really fun to do that. And there's definitely seasons for it. But I don't like the idea that you have to keep doing things and keep forcing yourself into like busy chaos, even if you don't like it, just because that's the norm. That gap between what we think we should want and what we genuinely do creates a lot of inattention. If the version of youth we've been convinced into is marketed as kind of constant excitement,
对未来的投资。是的，在你人生的某些阶段，这样做真的很有趣，而且肯定有其适用的时期。但我不喜欢这种想法：仅仅因为那是常态，你就得不断做事，逼着自己陷入忙乱的混乱中，哪怕你并不喜欢。我们以为自己想要的和我们真正想要的之间的巨大差距，会产生大量的分心。如果我们被灌输的青春版本被营销为持续的兴奋，
then choosing calm can feel kind of unfairly like you are failing at being young. You know, am I wasting this decade? Am I becoming, am I slowing down too soon? Am I going to regret this? Shocker, but it's, that's basically yet another yardstick, which we're encouraged to use as a measure of apparent success of our 20s. It's another thing that we're meant to judge ourselves by and always feel like we're not doing well enough because of. It's also not quite a shocker that since the
那么选择平静就会让人产生一种不公平的感觉，仿佛你在当年轻人这件事上失败了。你知道，“我在浪费这十年吗？”“我是不是太快慢下来了？”“我以后会后悔吗？”毫不奇怪，但这基本上是又一个标尺，我们被鼓励用它来衡量我们二十多岁时表面上的成功。这是我们用来评判自己的又一个标准，并且总是因此觉得自己做得还不够好。同样毫不奇怪的是，自
introduction of social media, this sense of dissonance has increased at a level of researchers and social scientists actually can't quite measure fast enough. One University of Washington study actually talks about how social media especially creates a state of, firstly, reduced self-reflection, secondly, narrowed attention, and thirdly, lack of individual interest, all of which is correlated with greater unhappiness. What these studies and what these findings basically say is that we get so focused on how others are living that the result of that is that we can no longer properly articulate or even imagine what we actually want because we're so consumed with what apparently is making them happy.
社交媒体问世以来，这种失调感已经上升到了研究人员和社会科学家甚至无法足够快地进行衡量的程度。华盛顿大学的一项研究实际上探讨了社交媒体是如何特别造成这样一种状态：首先，自我反省减少；其次，注意力狭隘；最后，缺乏个人兴趣，所有这些都与更高的不幸福感相关。这些研究和发现基本上说明的是，我们太专注于别人的生活，其结果就是，我们再也无法恰当地表达或甚至想象自己真正想要什么，因为我们太沉迷于那些显然让他们感到快乐的事情了。
I read this fantastic substack the other day that was like the loneliest place in the world is your full you page. And this author talks about like the massacism of the scroll where we kind of torture ourselves with the lives of people that we don't really want to be like but convince ourselves we do and kind of torture ourselves by not being like. This gets to like a very vital point. What our equal fear but also desire for the boring life is really,
前几天我读了一篇非常棒的Substack文章，里面写道：世界上最孤独的地方就是你的“为你推荐”页面。这位作者谈到了那种刷手机的自虐心理，我们用那些我们其实不想成为的人的生活来折磨自己，却说服自己我们想成为那样的人，并因为自己不像他们而折磨自己。这就触及了一个非常关键的点。我们对平淡生活的既恐惧又渴望，其实是被“错失恐惧症”（FOMO）操纵了。没错，这其实就是怎么回事。你未能或无法接受这正是你想要的，归根结底就是源于这种对错失的恐惧。心理学家在一项现已非常著名的2021年研究中，将错失恐惧症定义为一种持续的担忧，即其他人可能在没有我们的参与下获得更多有回报的体验，并伴随着持续与其他人正在做的事情保持连接的冲动。这是一种社交恐惧，因此也是一种相当的存在主义恐惧，直击我们不希望在经历中感到孤独或在世界上感到孤独的核心需求。
really being manipulated by is FOMO. Like, that's really what it is. Your failure or your inability to accept that this is what you actually want really comes down to this fear of missing out. Psychologists in a now very famous 2021 study defined the fear of missing out as a persistent apprehension that other people might be having more rewarding experiences without us, paired with the urge to stay continually connected to what everyone else is doing. It is a social fear and therefore quite an existential fear striking at our core need to kind of not be alone in the experience or not be alone in the world.
这就是为什么当选择非主流的生活时，我们会觉得错失了什么。这种感觉最有趣的地方在于，它实际上并不需要证据，也不需要你对现状感到特别不快乐就会发生。我们经常认为FOMO是那种非常孤独、待在卧室里、肉眼可见地被孤立的人才会有的经历，但我们可能正处于在家看电影的氛围中，左边是最好的朋友，右边是另一个朋友，盯着一个Instagram快拍，突然感到一阵痛苦和焦虑：
That is why we feel like we're missing out by choosing what is not the norm. What is so interesting about this feeling is that it doesn't actually need evidence or need you to feel especially unhappy with your current situation to occur. I think we often think of FOMO as like, that's what happens to people who are very lonely, in their bedroom, visibly isolated, but we can be in the middle of like a movie night at home, best friend on the left, other friend to the right, staring at an Instagram story and suddenly feeling this pain and anxiety
尽管我们此刻很幸福，但在别处的某个人，正在享受更多的快乐，那才是我们应该在的地方。别人比我们活得更精彩，因此我们把生活过错了。就像我们宁静的生活让我们失去了这种更令人兴奋的、更高阶的青春版本。FOMO在起源上是进化的产物。我们不能忘记这一点。它的本意是将我们赶回群体中。
that even though we are happy in this moment, somebody else, somewhere else, is having more fun and that's where we should be. Somebody else is more alive than we are, and therefore we are doing this wrong. Like our quiet life is costing us this like more exciting level or more exciting version of youth. Formo is evolutionary in origin. We can't forget that. It's meant to drive us back to the herd.
但在这些时刻，它所做的一切只是营造出一种压倒性的不胜任感。它没有让生活根据我们真正想要和感觉美好的方式展开，而是让我们在精神上始终朝着未走过的那条路看齐。它让我们专注于我们没有去的派对，没有被邀请的旅行，没有因为不去那旅行而遇到的人，以及如果我们当初能多说“几次好”、在外面待得更晚、更疲惫、买了那个物品——哪怕当时我们并不想要——本可以成为的那个版本的自己。2013年发表在《人类行为》杂志上的一项研究，进行了一系列
But all it does in these moments is create this overwhelming sense of inadequacy. Instead of letting life unfold according to what we actually want and what feels good, it keeps us mentally oriented towards the road not taken. It keeps us focused on the party we didn't go to, the trip we weren't invited on, the people we didn't meet by not going on that trip, the version of ourselves we imagined might have been if we had just said yes more often, stayed out later, been more tired, bought that item, even if in the moment we didn't want that. The 2013 study published in the journal, I think it's like human behavior, conducted a series
研究，探讨了FOMO的概念与人口统计、动机、幸福感等各种因素的关系，以及FOMO与行为和情感幸福感的关系，他们发现，FOMO不仅与较低的情绪、较低的整体生活满意度有关，还与更多来自我们自己生活的走神有关。经历更严重FOMO的人实际上自传体记忆较差，因为他们太沉迷于比较，以至于无法欣赏自己身处的好坏时刻。最痛苦的部分是，FOMO会让我们不信任自己的偏好。
of studies looking at the concept of FOMA in relation to various factors like demographics, motivation, well-being, as well as how phoma relates to behavior and emotional well-being, what they found was that not only was fomo linked to lower mood, lower overall life satisfaction, but also greater distraction from our own lives. People who were experiencing greater fomo actually had poor autobiographical memory, because they were so consumed with comparison, they couldn't appreciate the moment they were in good or bad. The really painful part is that FOMO can make us mistrust our own preferences.
正如我一直所说的那样，如果你能相信它的美好以及你对它的渴望，平淡的生活就是美好的。但如果你不能，因为你不断被别人的生活方式淹没，它就不会那么令人愉快。我认为我们可能对平淡的生活感到忧虑的另一个原因，是因为我们以为无聊、缓慢、平静、有规律意味着不再有乐趣，不再有兴奋，尤其是那种我们在混乱的夜晚或糟糕的决定或抓马中可能找到的兴奋。再说一次，我认为这有其时间和场合。尽管我有过这样的时刻，我也曾对那样的时刻感到后悔。
Like I've said this whole time, a boring life is beautiful if you can trust in its beauty and in your desire for it. But if you can't because you are constantly flooded with how other people are living, it's not going to feel as enjoyable. The other reason I think we may feel apprehension of the boring life is because we're We think that boring, slow, peaceful, regulated means no more fun, no more excitement, especially the kind of excitement we might find in like a messy night out or like bad decisions or drama. Again, I think there is a time and a place for that. As much as I have, I've had moments like that, I regret moments like that.
我也同样珍惜它们，因为它们是我之所以为我的基础。但我不需要再次吸取那些教训。我不需要一遍又一遍、没完没了地吸取那些教训。听着，我受够了。那些教训的意义何在，如果不是为了教会我做出更好的决定的话？在神经层面，是的，我们的大脑确实渴望新鲜感，但如果你已经身处那种情况并且知道自己不喜欢它，那就不是新鲜感了。
I also cherish them equally because they are fundamental to who I am. But I don't need to learn those lessons again. And I don't need to learn those lessons again and again and again. Like, I'm done. And what was the lesson for? if not kind of showing me how to make better decisions. On a neurological level, like, yeah, our brains do crave novelty, but that's not novelty if you've already been in that situation
我们绝对是，你知道的，被设定为倾向于令人惊讶和不可预测的事物，因为新鲜感会调动许多不同的大脑系统，这些系统与注意力、动机和奖励有关。这是我们大脑释放多巴胺的一个巨大因素，对吧？因为我们总是想走向那些感觉不熟悉的事物去学习，而且这是因为对快乐的期待和可能性。但我们必须明白，仅仅因为多巴胺很强大，仅仅因为我们的动机
and no, you don't like it. We are definitely, you know, wired to move towards what is surprising and unpredictable because novelty recruits so many different brain systems involved in attention and motivation and reward. It's a huge factor in how our brain releases dopamine, right? Because we're always wanting to move towards what feels unfamiliar to learn and because it's because of the anticipation and because of the possibility of pleasure. But we have to understand just because dopamine is powerful, just because our motivational
系统很强大，并不意味着它们总是把我们引向正确的方向。但我们常常迷失的地方在于我们如何解释对新鲜感的需求和这种多巴胺带来的良好感觉。尽管它们一开始感觉很相似，但新鲜感并不等同于纯粹的混乱或我们以为我们需要的那种忙碌的生活，对吧？多巴胺的产生和接收是有不同层级的。我们真正需要了解的是，你之前从这种混乱的生活中获得的多巴胺或任何快乐化学物质——也许你曾经很爱它并且正在过着这种生活——与你从长期满足感中获得的是不一样的。有时我们把混乱带来的情绪高潮和低谷误认为是我们在真正生活的证据，
systems are powerful, doesn't mean they're always leading us in the right direction. But where we often get lost is in how we interpret that need for novelty and the feel good of this dopamine. Even though they feel similar at first, novelty isn't the same as pure chaos or the kind of busy lives that we think we need, right? There are different levels of how dopamine is produced and received. What we really need to understand is that the dopamine or whatever pleasure chemicals you were previously getting from this chaotic life that maybe you loved and that you were living is not the same that you're going to get from long-term gratification. Sometimes we mistake the emotional highs and lows of chaos for evidence that we're really living,
就像二十多岁的人应该过的那种生活。但这种即时的刺激感并没有给我们带来真正的新鲜感、好奇心和享受所带来的更深层奖励。事实上，伦敦大学学院神经学系2016年的一项研究实际上发现，它确实会产生带偏的选择。我们对快速多巴胺、即时快乐的追求，是的，可能会给我们带来更快的结果，但它会在晚些时候造成情绪崩溃。你知道，我们处于持续被激活的状态。
like how somebody in their 20 should be living. But that immediate feeling of stimulation really gives us the deeper reward that true novelty and curiosity and enjoyment does. In fact, one 2016 study from the neurology department at the University, University College of London, I actually found that it can actually create biased choices. Like our striving for quick dopamine, for instant pleasure, yes, may give us a faster result, but it creates an emotional crash later on. You know, we're constantly activated.
我们不一定得到了丰富。再次强调，这就是平淡生活的美妙之处。它把你从这种需要更多的持续状态中抽离出来，从接纳、期待中抽离出来，并允许你真正去选择你的身体和心灵想要流向何处，以及你真正想把注意力放在哪里。就像，真正的新鲜感、真正的多巴胺会扩展和丰富你。它存在于学习新东西中。它存在于加深与朋友或伴侣的亲密关系中。
We're not necessarily enriched. And again, this is the beauty of the boring life. It takes you out of this constant state of needing more, of acceptance, of anticipation. and allows you to just actually choose where your body and your mind wants to flow to and where you actually want to put your attention towards. Like, real novelty, real dopamine expands and enriches you. It's in learning something new. It's in deepening intimacy with friends or your partner.
它在于融入大自然。它在于对长期项目或挑战的奉献。我认为这就是平淡生活能让你做到的。好了。这里先做个短暂的休息，稍后我们将讨论倾向于平淡无奇生活的意向性和接纳性，在人际关系和情感上能为你带来什么心理层面的益处，以及为什么它对你如此有益。请继续收听。多伦多自豪月。自豪节是你创造自己的空间、庆祝
It's getting into nature. It's dedication to long-term projects or challenges. I think that's what a boring life allows you to do. Okay. a short break here before we talk about what leaning into the intentionality and acceptance of a boring, lame life can do for you psychologically in terms of your relationships and emotionally and why it's so good for you. Stay with us. Pride Month Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space, to celebrate
你存在的契机。iHeart Radio很荣幸能成为多伦多自豪节的官方赞助商。我们永不止步。庆祝自豪。点燃爱意，收听IHeart Pride Canada。你全天候的电台流媒体，也是你多伦多自豪节庆祝活动唯一需要的播放列表。自豪节太棒了，因为它让一大群人获得了前所未有的曝光度。多伦多，我们有很多值得庆祝的事。自豪节快乐。iHeart Radio。
your existence. Iheart Radio is proud to be an official sponsor of Pride Toronto Festival. and we won't stop. Celebrate Pride. Turn up the love and listen to IHeart Pride Canada. Your 24-7 radio stream and the only playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations. Pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that they've never had before. We have a ton to celebrate Toronto. Happy Pride. IHeart Radio.
当时感觉这一幕仿佛持续了永恒。我以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。这里什么都没有。那些眼神里，它们变得漆黑。这把我吓得魂飞魄散。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。
In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything here. Inside those eyes, they turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir.
可以说是你职业生涯中最大的一起案件吗？是的，长官。针对儿童的强奸和谋杀。可以说是最糟糕的罪行了。我想是的。人们醒醒吧。我是那个看到克里瓦茨和德皮波实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，
Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse,
在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说我是无辜的。我至死也不会承认。悲伤。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听《The Devil's Quarry》。要想无广告且独家收听《The Devil's Quarry》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《快乐101与霍达·科特比》的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话，
appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the group. Grief. Listen to the Devil's Quarry on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear The Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people,
比如当演员奥利维娅·芒分享她是如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌。那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。我并没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听由霍达·科特比主持的《快乐101》。主流媒体充斥着对无家可归者的残酷刻画。那些充满羞辱和指责、将无家可归者描绘成
Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer. And that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of the unhoused. Stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as.
单一群体的故事。《We The End House》是一档正在改变这种现状的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，节目的创作者兼主持人，多年来我一直为无家可归者及其倡导者创造一个可以讲述他们自己故事的空间。仅在过去的几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQIA+社群，以及制定影响无家可归者生存状态法律的政策制定者。《Weidian Hous》是一档荣获两次韦比奖和信号奖的节目，未来还将有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾做客。本周收听我对吉尔·威彻博士的采访，她是一位从街头医生转型为网红的人，
as a monolith. We The End House is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator, and host, and for years I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhouse parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Weidian Hous is a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill Witcher, a street doctor turned influencer
她对无家可归者社群的工作在网络和她的社群中产生了巨大影响。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Weythian House》。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Chams》播客中，我们将与文化界最炙手可热的大咖对话，比如斯韦·李。
whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Weythian House on the IHard Radio app, Apple podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture. like Sway Lee.
你意识到自己有多传奇了吗？我很感激。我虽然看到了，但我觉得，天哪，我还有好多事要做。就像王子，他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在才发行了大约5张。就像，这就是我们必须前进的速度。没错，这是一个好心态。你还将听到来自行业传奇和嘻哈先驱的故事，比如法布·五世·弗雷迪。
Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got like so much more to do. Like Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now. Like, that's the rate we gotta be going. Yep, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddie.
我导演了纳斯的早期MV。哪一个？《One Love》。哇。是的。我真的在他的皇后桥公寓里拍摄。他妈妈当时还在那个公寓里。纳斯才刚刚开始走红。
I directed when Nas's early videos. Which one? One love. Wow. Yes. I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. Nans was just beginning to take off.
他老爸以前住在我在哈莱姆区附近。他爸爸向他介绍了大量，你知道的，有觉悟的东西，他造就了一个年轻的神童。无论哪个时代，《Drink Chams》都会为你带来最大牌的明星和最毫无保留的对话。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《Drink Chams》。
His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff, and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
为了让你更加确信社交媒体让你痛恨的所谓平淡生活中的美好，让我们来谈谈当你接受更慢的节奏时，你会看到的四个重大改变和好处。第一，看似更安静的生活，往往是情绪调节更好、极端低谷更少的生活。当我们的生活变得过度刺激时，我们的大脑会在高唤醒状态下花费更多时间。皮质醇、肾上腺素保持升高，注意力变得碎片化，我们开始从反应性的角度而不是意向性的角度行事。关于压力的研究、关于神经系统调节的研究始终表明，
In order to convince you even more of the beauty in your so-called boring life that social media has convinced you to hate, let's talk about the four major changes and benefits you will see when you accept a slower pace. Number one, what looks like a quieter life is often a life with better emotional regulation and fewer extreme lows. When our lives become overstimulated, our brains spend more time in the state of hyperarousal. Cortisol, adrenaline, they stay elevated, attention becomes fragmented, and we begin operating from a place of reactivity rather than intentionality. Research on stress, research on nervous system regulation consistently shows that
长期的过度刺激会降低我们控制情绪的能力，正如我们之前所提到的，这会降低我们做出基于价值观的好决策的能力。我们对小的不便、小的挫折在情绪上变得更加脆弱，因为我们的基准压力已经很高了，所以不需要太多就能把我们推向崩溃边缘。安静的生活往往反映出相反的情况。它表明更强的自我调节能力，因为这里面进行了一些情绪筛选，对吧？你不会对所有事情都说好。你不会对去任何地方都说好，尤其是当你现在知道了代价之后。心理学家有时将此描述为拥有更大的耐受窗口，基本上。你能够更好地围绕你能耐受的事情做出决定，并且能够更好
chronic overstimulation reduces our capacity for emotional control and, as we mentioned before, reduces our capacity to make good value-based decisions. We become more emotionally vulnerable to small inconveniences, to small frustrations, because our baseline stress is already so high, it doesn't take much to kind of tip us over. A quieter life often reflects the opposite. And it indicates stronger self-regulation skills because there is some emotional curation going on, right? You're not just saying yes to everything. You're not saying yes to being everywhere, especially when you now know the cost. psychologists sometimes describe this is having a greater window of tolerance, basically. You're better able to make decisions around what you can tolerate and you're better
地扩展你处理突发事件的能力，因为你没有用那些你实际上不需要忍受的东西不断透支你的情绪系统。还有关于一种叫做“享乐适应”的研究。你可能以前在播客里听过这个。但关于纯粹的新鲜感、纯粹的混乱和纯粹的兴奋，问题在于，我们的大脑对它习以为常了。所以你需要越来越多、越来越多的刺激才能让自己开心。你的神经系统会重新校准。因此，当你习惯了这种大事、大刺激时，小的快乐就不再感觉那么快乐了。所以回到这种
able to expand your capacity to deal with things coming out of the blue because you're not constantly taxing your emotional systems with stuff you actually don't need to endure. There's also research around something called hedonic adaptation. You've probably heard about this on the podcast before. But the thing about raw novelty and raw chaos and raw excitement is that, our brain gets really used to it. And so you need more and more and more to enjoy yourself. Your nervous system recalibrates. And so it makes it so that small pleasures don't feel as pleasurable anymore when you're used to this big, like big stuff. So going back to this
平静、缓慢的生活，能让你实际上把它往反方向重新校准。你能够真正地对那些你可以也应该心存感激的事物有更多的欣赏。其次，不言而喻的是，更无趣的生活往往也是一条拥有更好界限的生活，因为在那个时候，最重要的是你的情感和心理中心，而不是别人对你的偏好，不是你是否因为没有露面而让某人失望。你能相当快地弄清楚谁是因为真正的你而喜欢你，谁是喜欢你能提供给他们的东西。当然，伴随着更好的边界而来的，还有更大的压力。哲学家们，就像，人们谈论当下已经很久很久了。
peaceful slower life allows you to actually recalibrate it back in the opposite direction. You're able to actually have more of an appreciation for just things that you can and should be grateful for. Secondly, it goes without saying, but a more boring life is also often a life with better boundaries, because at that point, what matters most is your emotional and your psychological centre, not someone else's preferences for you, not whether you disappointed somebody by not showing up. You get pretty clear on who likes you for you compared with who likes what you can offer them fairly quickly. And of course, like, along with better boundaries, it comes with greater pressure. What philosophers, like, people have been talking about presence for ages.
当然，伴随着更好的边界，它也伴随着更强的临在感（活在当下）。正如哲学家们——字面意义上数百年来的言论——所说，这是生命最珍贵的礼物，因为没有它，其他一切都不可能实现。就像，那是你没有意识到的。你并没有真正在那些混乱、浮华和兴奋的时刻活在当下。有成千上万的古代文献、成千上万的书籍、成千上万的文章都在探讨如何真正从一个时刻中汲取一切。会调动你的感官和心智去欣赏我们大多数人忽略的细节。不出所料，
And of course, alongside better boundaries, it also comes with greater presence. What philosophers, like, literally hundreds of years have said is like life's most precious gift because nothing else is possible without it. Like, that's what you don't realize. You're not really present for those moments of chaos and, like, glamour and excitement. There are thousands of ancient texts, thousands of books, thousands of articles that have been written about how to really take everything from a moment. would tune your senses and your mind to appreciate details that most of us ignore. And no surprise here,
他们建议很大一部分往往是花更多时间去体验无聊，花更多时间在平凡之中。换句话说，就像，就像慢下来哪怕仅仅一秒钟。去真正注意你的生活，而不是不断试图改善它。你有没有回看过一段非常精彩的假期，或者一个非常精彩的夜晚，或者一个非常精彩的生日，然后意识到，其实我不记得我以为我会记住的事情。我只记得那些最奇怪的小细节。这正是我的重点。你记住的是那些感觉最自然的时刻，因为你的临在感最强。我不认为生活发生在巨大字号中。我认为它发生在小字号里。而未能调频到这一点，可能意味着在更深层面上未能充分生活。这让我想起了我前几天看到的一句话，大意是：当你的生活不可避免地在眼前闪回时，那是你自己的生活，还是你为了给别人留下深刻印象或为了在网上看起来光鲜亮丽而捏造的生活？那会仅仅是分心和恐惧的宏大时刻中零星的活在当下吗？即使在你做得很好的时候，也害怕自己做得还不够。
a big part of their advice is often spend more time being bored, spend more time within the ordinary. Translation, just like, just like slow the fuck down for just a second. Just actually notice your life rather than constantly trying to improve it. You ever look back at a really amazing holiday or like a really amazing night out or a really amazing birthday and realize like, I don't actually remember the things I thought I would. I remember the strangest little details. That is exactly my point. You remember the moments that felt most natural because presence was greatest. I don't think life happens in a big font. I think it happens in the little font. And a failure to tune into that may just mean actually a deeper failure to live fully. It kind of reminds me of something I saw
真的，我认为我们对较慢的、所谓的平淡生活日益增长的偏好，是我们正在逐渐醒悟到一个现实：在网上看到的那些东西是永远无法追赶的。你从中感受到的只有糟糕的感觉。也许这是一种更深刻的现实：如果我做了所有这一切，我仍然不快乐；如果我试图跟上潮流，却依然痛苦，这一切究竟是为了什么？这已经不再有说服力了。
the other day, which was like a quote that said, when your life inevitably flashes before your eyes, will it be yours or will it be what you made your life into to impress others or to look good online? Will it just be snatches of presence amongst bigger moments of distraction and fear that you're not doing enough even when you are? Really, I think our growing preference for the slower, so-called boring life is that we're kind of waking up to this reality that there's no keeping up with what we see online. There's only ever feeling bad about it. it. Maybe it's an even deeper reality of like, if I'm doing all of this and I'm still unhappy, if I'm trying to keep up and I'm still miserable, what is it for? Like, this isn't convincing
所有那些其他忙碌的时刻，那些试图符合你用青春应该做什么的刻板印象的时刻。它们并不总是能给你带来快乐。但临在感绝对能。我们在关于正念的研究中看到了这一点。我们在关于心理当下时刻的健康和觉察的研究中看到了这一点，它与较少的情绪反应、更好的行为调节、更高的生活满意度、更好的人际关系等等息息相关，这些都是时髦词汇，基本上，人们就是快乐的，过着慢生活的人是快乐的，而且更快乐。他们基本上破解了快乐的密码。他们走向感觉美好的事物，哪怕在别人看来这似乎很无聊。我认为这是一个很好的问题，可以为本期节目画上句号，那就是：
anymore. All those other busy moments, those like moments of trying to fit the stereotype of like what you're meant to be doing with your youth. Like, they don't always make you happy. And presence definitely does. We see this in research on mindfulness. We see this in research on psychological present moment health and awareness it's associated with less emotional reactivity better behaviour regulation more life satisfaction better relationships blah blah blah those are all buzz words basically people are just happy people who live slowly are happy and happier they basically cracked the code of happiness they go towards what feels good even if to others it seems boring i think it's a great question to finish this episode on which is like
到头来，当你抗拒平淡的生活时，你究竟在逃避什么？当你把其他一切调低或关闭时，你其实害怕会有什么想法留在那里？就像，你究竟在用什么分散自己的注意力？随着年龄的增长，我认为你越会意识到，与自己的思想相处比别人告诉你的要困难得多。几年前我经历过这样一段时期，那时寂静感觉像是一个巨大的威胁，至少对我来说，是一个强烈的信号，表明我做得还不够，因为我在二十多岁时有这些需要用经历去填补的时刻。我克服这一点的唯一方法是，A，总是让自己忙碌，但B，总是开着电视或音乐或播放着某个节目。我需要被刺激包围。
In the end, when you resist the boring life, what are you really avoiding? What thoughts are you actually afraid are going to be there when you turn everything else down or off? Like, what are you actually distracting yourself with? The older you get, I think the more you realize that being with your own thoughts is much harder than people tell you. I went through a period of years back when like silence felt like such a threat, like such an intense sign, at least for me, that like, I wasn't doing enough because I had these moments in my 20s that I needed to fill with experiences. And my like only way to overcome that was A, to just always be busy, but B, to always have the TV on or music or a show playing. Like I needed to be surrounded by stimulation.
每当我身边没有其他人的时候，那种感觉比FOMO还要强烈。这就像是对自己做得不够的一种深深的恐惧和遗憾。而我真正隐藏的，我认为，又是这种感觉：时间很短。这就是每个人都在告诉我应该而且会喜欢的东西。它其实并没有让我快乐。但如果每个人都在这样做，我不想错过。这简直就像是一场心理不安全感的饕餮盛宴。让我们直说吧，过度工作、噪音、忙碌、身边总得有点动静，这就是
And whenever I had these moments where I wasn't around other people, it was bigger than FOMO. It was like this deep fear of regret that I wasn't doing enough. And what I was really, like, I think, hiding from was, again, this sense that, like, time is short. This is what everybody is telling me I should and will enjoy. It's not actually making me happy. But if everybody is doing it, I don't want to miss out. Like, it was just a whole smorgasbord of, like, psychological insecurity. And let's just say, like, overworking, noise, busyness, always having something on, that is
每当我独自一人时，那种感觉比错失恐惧症（FOMO）还要强烈。就像是一种对做得不够的深深的遗憾恐惧。而我真正躲避的，我想，再次是那种时间短暂的感觉。这就是每个人都告诉我我应该也将会享受的东西。它实际上并没有让我快乐。但如果每个人都在这样做，我又不想错过。总之，这就像是一盘心理不安全感的什锦拼盘。而且可以说，过度工作、噪音、忙碌、总是有事可做，那就是
as much a coping mechanism as anything else. Being busy is the silent coping mechanism. Just like an alcoholic uses alcohol to silence the fear and uncertainty and grief, a busyholic uses the rush of a packed schedule to do the same so that they can crash at the end of the night and put off that self-reflection for another day. There's an absolutely fascinating paper published in the journal. The journal is called Science, basically. And it looks at this. And the researchers wanted to know why people struggle so deeply with being alone or being bored. And they found that if they just left people in a room for like 15 minutes by themselves, they would literally start shocking themselves with electric shocks to avoid that discomfort.
这与其说别的，不如说是一种应对机制。忙碌就是那种无声的应对机制。就像嗜酒者用酒精来掩盖恐惧、不确定和悲伤一样，工作狂也会利用排得满满当当的日程带来的紧迫感来达到同样的目的，这样他们就能在深夜筋疲力尽时倒头大睡，从而把这种自我反思推迟到改天再做。学术期刊上曾发表过一篇绝对精彩的论文。这本杂志基本上就叫《科学》。它研究了这一现象。研究人员想要弄清楚，为什么人们在独处或感到无聊时会感到如此痛苦。他们发现，如果只是把人们独自关在一个房间里大约15分钟，他们甚至会字面意义上开始电击自己，以此来逃避那种难受的感觉。
Because they were so not used to just being with themselves and being present in the moment. And the thing was, it's not boredom that they were scared of. They were scared of loneliness. They were scared of things that they hadn't thought deeply enough about. And I think that's where our real fear of like boredom comes from. Our real fear of the boring life comes from, I should say, is like, what's going to be, what sense of inadequacy is hiding behind that. So I think that's really like why we can't accept what we know we kind of want,
因为他们太不习惯独处以及活在当下了。关键在于，他们害怕的并不是无聊。他们害怕的是孤独。他们害怕那些自己没有深入思考过的事情。我认为，这就是我们真正对无聊感到恐惧的根源。我应该说，我们对无聊生活的真正恐惧来自于：隐藏在那之下的那种无价值感究竟是什么。所以我想，这才是为什么我们无法接受我们明明知道自己想要的东西，
but why getting to the point where we can be like, oh, I'm actually okay to slow down. And when I rest, I'm going to rest. and when I'm being present, I'm going to be present. Like when we get to that point, all those things, yes, come to be. When we're present, we're happier, or all of that. I think we also just finally get a grip and get a grasp of like, okay, what do I actually want? And that's what the value is in accepting and embracing what a lot of people and social media
但为什么能达到这样一种状态——我们可以觉得，哦，我其实可以慢下来。当我休息时，我就好好休息；当我活在当下时，我就好好活在当下。当我们达到那种状态时，所有这些东西，是的，自然就会到来。当我们活在当下时，我们会更快乐，诸如此类。我想我们也终于能够掌握并理解，好吧，我到底想要什么？这就是接受并拥抱许多人和社交媒体所不愿让你接受的东西的价值所在，
and companies and marketing doesn't want you to accept, which is that actually you need a lot less than you think you do and that you actually, when you remove all these, like, distractions and all these other things, you actually get to the core of, like, what you desire without all this, like, kind of junk surrounding it. So that, my friends, is my argument for the boring life. To summarize very, very quickly, why are we so opposed to the boring life? Well, because we've been sold this idea that, especially in our 20s, means we're failing, it means that we're settling, it means that we've, like, we've grown out of our youth too quickly. That's literally not the case. We can still have novelty, excitement,
而公司和营销号也不希望你接受这一点，那就是实际上你需要的比你想象的要少得多，而且当你剥离所有这些干扰和所有其他乱七八糟的东西时，你实际上就能直达你真正渴望的核心，而没有周围这些垃圾的包围。所以，我的朋友们，这就是我对无聊生活的主张。非常非常快地总结一下，为什么我们如此反对无聊的生活？嗯，因为我们被灌输了一种观念，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，这意味着我们失败了，这意味着我们在妥协，这意味着我们太快告别了青春。事实根本并非如此。我们依然可以拥有新鲜感、刺激感，
adventure without stringing ourselves along and without getting to a point of, like, complete exhaustion. And there is real maturity in accepting that, like, you can do it all. If you go a little bit slower and you can actually enjoy it, a great way to, like, accept that is to really dig down, deeper into like what is behind your fear of a boring life and what it represents to slash what you're actually trying to avoid. And I think at the end of the day, yeah, you just end up happier. You end up more fulfilled. So I hope it's something that like if you've been kind of opposed to, you can come to accept and realize the beauty in. As always, I want to thank our researcher Libby for her help with this episode. If you have made it this far and you are listening on Spotify,
和冒险，而无需把自己逼入绝境，也无需让自己陷入精疲力竭的境地。接受你可以做到这一切，只要稍微放慢脚步，并且真正去享受它，这才是真正的成熟。接受这一点的一个绝佳方法，就是深入挖掘你对无聊生活的恐惧背后的真正原因，以及它所代表的含义，或者你究竟在试图逃避什么。我想说到底，是的，你最终会更快乐。你最终会得到更多的成就感。所以我希望，如果你一直有点排斥这种生活，你能学会接受并认识到其中的美。和往常一样，我要感谢我们的研究员莉比（Liby）对本期节目的帮助。如果你听到了这里，并且正在用Spotify收听，
I'm trying to think about what our emoji will be for the day. Maybe like an olive. An olive branch, a white dove. You choose. Just so I know that you've made it this far, thank you for listening to the end. If you want to read a transcript version of this episode, you can do that on Substac.
我在想要是我们今天的表情符号是什么呢。也许是一颗橄榄。一根橄榄枝，一只白鸽。你来选。只要让我知道你听到了这里，感谢你收听到最后。如果你想阅读本期节目的文字稿版本，你可以在Substack上找到它。
You can also watch this episode on Netflix. You might not want to rewatch it. You can watch another episode on Netflix. Or you can follow us on Instagram, all the ways that you can find us, reach us, talk to it. us, talk to me, watch, engage with the podcast more, will be in the description below. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself.
你还可以在Netflix上观看本期节目。你可能不想再看一遍。你可以在Netflix上观看另一期节目。或者你可以在Instagram上关注我们，所有能找到我们、联系我们、与我们对话、与我对话、观看并更多参与到播客互动中的方式，都会在下方的简介中。但在此之前，请注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。
I hope this episode was a little bit convincing. We will talk very, very soon. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, How to If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
希望这期节目能有一点说服力。我们很快就会再聊。快乐是必不可少的，但它也是难以捉摸的。不过现在，有一种崭新而令人兴奋的方式来开启你通往更快乐生活之旅：《快乐101》。这是一个由我主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来将你的快乐最大化，请收听这些坦诚、振奋且感人的直播闲聊。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用。搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by craving. and DePripo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse,
由霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby）主持的《快乐101》由CVS呈现。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓坏了。人们醒醒吧。我就是那个目睹克雷文和德皮波谋杀案发生的人。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）没有表现出丝毫悔意，
appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rapaport Stereo Podcast,
在被判处最高刑期时显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我将把这个秘密带进棺材里。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方，收听《恶魔采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）之《骨头谷》（Bone Valley）专栏。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特（Michael Rappaport），我的播客《我是拉帕波特立体声播客》（The I Am Rapaport Stereo Podcast），
is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rap Report on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life?
与你听过的任何人都不一样。如果你正在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何其他引起我注意的事情的强烈观点，那就立即订阅吧。这个名叫杰法尔·杰克逊（Jafar Jackson）的小伙子绝对应该因其对迈克尔·杰克逊的塑造而获得提名。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《我是拉帕波特立体声播客》。每个家庭都有它的秘密。但是，当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？
That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is,
那绝不是一个无辜之人的眼神。每个人都在对我说谎，隐瞒他们究竟是谁吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我不得不做的事情。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方，收听《深入卧底：好好先生》（Deep Cover the Family Man）。这里有一件本不该如此复杂的事情，
getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority of Black City, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
拆除一座种族主义雕像。这里还有一件本该容易得多、却并非如此的事情，那就是在原地竖起一座新的雕像。我是阿克拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《叛逆精神》第二季讲述的就是这两件事。当我看着这些雕像倒塌时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，那里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役人民的致敬还要多，这究竟意味着什么。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客上收听《叛逆精神》第二季，
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或在任何你获取播客的地方。这是一档IHeart播客。人类品质保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。